我们现在决定要生这个孩子，
算账的时候先别算别人，
先只算我自己，
为什么要，
因为你一旦把它算进去了之后，
将来比如说你住院啊，
产检啊，
那个月儿嫂的钱啊，
月嫂的钱啊，
她如果出的不积极的话，
你就会难过。
现在怀孕五个多月了，
应该怎么调整心态，
我今年37岁了，
和她前夫分开已经有四年了，
跟前夫有两个儿子，
一个9岁，
一个10岁，
但是前夫是属于典型的NPP，
但是离婚也是去了半条命，
那现在是不给见孩子的，
我有两年是没有见过孩子的，
就是我感觉要见这两个孩子是很难的，
我想等到他们再大一点，
能够有自主权的再过来找我，
我现在是谈了一个，
他是我们公司的上法，
他到50岁年龄方面会有点大，
我自己的年收入大概是4~50个，
现在存款估计就是150个的样子。
我们在一起两年了，
性格还是挺合适的，
他对我也挺迁就，
因为我自己本身脾气也还挺大的，
对方也是离异，
他有一儿一女，
一个在上大学，
一个已经成年了，
结婚了。
她的身家预估在3000个的样子吧，
我们是在计划外怀孕了，
在当时她就说一定要我就提出了买房子。
我们在一起两年，
她在我身上大概花了二三十个吧，
也我提出了买房子，
她也同意了。
但是他就说先给首付，
给50个，
他给的有点磨叽，
那我心里面有点不舒服，
因为我在一起呢，
就是说我也不是一定要什么东西，
但是你如果让我生这个孩子，
我肯定会提要求，
拖拖拉拉就拖到了现在，
但是房子现在已经交完首付了，
就比如一些什么小的费用啊，
就是比如说契税啊，
或者是什么把，
因为是买二手房，
也只需要简单装修一下，
他的第一反应会是说，
那你就自己给这个钱，
我也不是说一点都不想出钱，
但是我不喜欢他这种下意识的反应，
现在我就是担心，
就是说这个孩子我自己又有一点想留，
确实是有点想留，
因为前面的孩子也看不到我的离婚，
我也不太想公开，
同一个公司我也没有公开过，
因为不喜欢同事在背后议论，
所以我跟他的关系呢，
我也不是很想公开，
我们也没有结婚的计划，
他是愿意公开的，
但是我不愿意公开，
我这种情况应不应该留下这个孩子，
你的这份工作，
年收入四五十万的工作非常稳定吗？
如果你现在比较稳定的，
就算怀了孕，
生完孩子了之后，
回到这个职场，
还能够有这份工作在吗？
第6的，
那如果是这个情况的话，
那咱倒是不怕，
咱因为一年能收四五十万的话，
咱可以请育儿嫂，
咱就算花个8万块钱的成本请个育儿嫂的话，
咱也是可以把孩子养大的，
有人帮你带孩子的，
就是他会负责，
他对孩子还挺负。
责的，
你说谁对孩子负责，
我方现在自己的孩子呀，
我敢相信，
就是说这孩子生下来肯定是会负责的，
这是我会讲的比较好的，
是这样啊，
姐妹，
我们现在决定要生这个孩子，
算账的时候先别算别人，
先只算我自己为什么要过，
因为你一旦把它算进去了之后，
将来比如说你住院啊，
产检啊，
那个月儿嫂的钱啊，
月嫂的钱啊，
他如果出的不积极的话，
你就会难过，
就会影响你的心态，
态负心态，
我不喜欢这种心态来折磨我自己，
所以呢，
咱釜底抽薪，
我生这个孩子完全是为了我自己，
为什么呢？
因为我前面两个孩子我看不着，
我心里想孩子，
但是我心里又无法排遣，
我生这个孩子完全是因为我自己，
我有这个经济条件，
且我想生一个孩子，
你要说釜底抽薪到这种程度的话，
以后你跟他关系反而好相处，
你不给他任何压力，
不给他任何暗示，
他稍微愿意给孩子付出一点了，
他说我给孩子买个2万块钱的保险嘛，
你就觉得像捡钱似的，
他稍微愿意给孩子付个什么月儿嫂的钱了，
或者付个什么月嫂的钱啊，
你就觉得哎呦挺好的，
还帮衬我了，
那邢台就不一样，
反正你也不打算跟他领结婚证，
就这意思，
你就别把他当成一个老公看，
你就把他当成一个生孩子的这么一个不拖后腿的伙伴看，
他不拖我后腿，
你会以乱花我的钱耶呦，
他还能给孩子。
受一点儿是一点儿哈，
能给我帮衬一点儿是一点儿，
你要是说调整成这样的心态的话，
你俩相处很轻松啊，
不然的话你老委屈很难过，
你到时候产后抑郁，
到时候工作再出点啥问题的话，
那你就可惨了。
其实我现在就是在这个，
我心里态也没纠结，
那你就得釜底抽薪，
就是第一我生这个孩子是因为我想生正好了，
我现在都已经37了，
我还能生正好，
他孩子他爸智商还不错，
能力还不错，
孩子他爸还有一点家底儿，
最起码我这个孩子不是说我当小，
不是说私生子，
他是你情我愿的产物，
至少我这个孩子他还有继承的资格，
就这么小问题，
这个我明白，
但是如果我调整不好这个心态的话，
就是我现在没办法确定我能调整好这种心态，
我是不是可以叫他一次性给钱，
不可能，
你要相信老登们的智商，
不可能一次性给钱，
那我明白了，
好，
就这样啊，
拜拜，
我直播间有没有老哥哥，
有没有五十几岁的老哥哥，
你们会一次性给钱吗？
你们要充分相信姜是老的啦，
不可能的，
因为他怕你拿着他的钱找小鲜肉，
他怕你拿着他的钱别的男的啊，
刚刚有人说啊，
龙飞姐的直播间没有老哥哥没有有钱的老哥哥有，
他们不说话，
他们只是悄悄的点头，
默默的认同，
他们不说话，
记得点赞关注哦。